hi everybody it's kevin van ort here and
we've chosen our game of the month for
tuned 2015 and that choice was her story
and instead of doing the usual video we
decided instead to get four of us
together who have all played her story
and do a very spoiler heavy discussion
about the game it'll be a short one and
so we're gonna focus on the biggest
element we feel about the game which
isn't exactly what human body I guess
you could say committed this crime but
instead to talk about whether we believe
that her is one her that has essentially
two personalities or are we talking
about two individual people who you
would assume are twins and I'm gonna
start this discussion with Randolph
Ramsey because he is the one of the four
of us that is firmly in the two-person
camp look I was waylaid I came into this
expecting to have more people support to
pursue theory but then you told me you
are going with a single person yeah so
just just to recap so there is no Hannah
what's the other characters name Eve Eve
there's just one person that you guys
are claiming I I seem to think and let
me just say where I am at this stage
right because it may change depending on
how much you've actually seen in the
game I've uncovered the achievement that
set up 75% of the way through associate
7 to 75 percent of the videos it seems
to me that the simplest explanation to
this right now is that there are two
women it seems to me that it was Eve who
was living with Simon it was Eve who
committed the deed it was Eve and Hannah
together who tried to cover it up but
then afterwards you know there was a
realization from Hannah
it was either a realization from Hannah
that you know she couldn't trust even
therefore went to the police or they
were using that time to have some time
for a
to actually escape and she felt Hannah
felt that she was comfortable in going
to the police and admitting her role in
this scheme because she was not a real
person the in terms of not having an
identity so because she like lived in
the Attic and it lives across the street
and tattoos there's waters that
obviously has a lot to say about this oh
man well like I just think there was
there's a moment early on where you
first hear the Nate where you first hear
her talking about Eve or Hannah I forget
which one first is mentioned it's like
oh wait she thinks there's someone else
involved here that was a really weird
moment for me and I think that's one of
the sort of first intrigues you get in
this game that's so so intriguing and so
rich with like different things to
discover in different perspectives to
kind of stumble upon is that the the
video where she's going oh why did you
have to mention Hannah and does the tap
that was an interesting one yeah where
she's like she thinks the cameras not on
it's one of the few that I've seen that
she is not addressing she's not in an
interview like the interviewers out of
the room right I'm gonna add something
to that I'm regarding the the NOC code
the tap code as it were because several
of us went and decoded that so it's that
the first time the time you're talking
about that I encountered that it says
love you the second one is a is a sort
of a weird misspelled BYD Hanan thing
which I've interpreted as by Hannah
which and the way I've and part of
what's gone into my feeling that this is
one person suffering from you know a
dissociative disorder is well there are
lots of reasons for it but one of them
is that I believe that that is how
essentially the two personalities
communicate or draw each other out that
you in both of those cases where she
uses the tap code I actually believe
that she switches in the midst of that
video simply by communicating the tap so
it was it my interpretation of them so
this game is a game that lets you like
there is no I guess one solution to this
mystery that I've seen yeah I don't get
to the Internet's like so choice quiz
yeah
so what is it like what piece of
evidence over and above a feeling that
you get that it's one person was there
like a piece of evidence or something
that you saw that firmly put you into
the one person so if I could jump in
here for a second I want to actually go
back to like backtrack a little bit and
just say like even in this conversation
that we've had so far there have been
it's confusing as to who is talking
throughout the entire thing like is it
Eve is it Hannah I was when I play the
game I was always in the camp that
Hannah was living him Simon Hannah's
married just married Sami and then eve
had an affair with Simon and then Hannah
if there were two people and then Hannah
ended up killing Simon out of anger but
the reason why like one of the main
reasons why I mean the one person
Candice just because of all that
confusion the second biggest like
concrete evidence that I have for it is
both of them the the woman who's all
sensibly calling yourself Hannah and the
woman who is calling yourself Eve there
are two different videos with them
saying the exact same thing about what
they were doing on the Friday night and
that specifically is something that
really struck me as evidence for it than
being the second however - I'm gonna say
something that goes against my actual
view to give you a counterpoint to that
which is it's discussed several times
that the two women right what happens in
videos and is presumably in journals
their journals right and they are
actually discussing what to say so the
point of about that video either way you
look at it is that it's ultra rehearsed
the question then is is it ultra
rehearsed because it's the same person
or is it ultra rehearsed because they
got their stories done so well together
by communicating if they are individuals
you know that's actually really creepy
the fact that it's almost the same thing
that they're saying so very rehearsed
the question is is it to people that
reversed it gorgeous I mean it is the
same though isn't it like they both say
that they went to Glasgow that they
slept in a car and then they came back
they took a shower they haven't like
they fell asleep in their bed and then
they didn't see Simon and the name
specifically mention Glasgow because all
I remember is she comes home she turns
the key the key tip that the tea kettle
and all that but I don't think she's
Pacific that one cliff doesn't mention
Glasgow okay and I wasn't I thought I
didn't even think they both claimed
I thought that was one of the ones that
moved maybe support Randi's SAP what was
that Eve so just made that trip I
believe just to clarify montana alex is
right over in my notes here which i
think every player who does that story
so i did right there Eva's primary so
you're right it like Eve is the person
out so like going facet of this
personality or the two people and Hannah
is the secret yeah she's one who has
relationships with Simon's parents who
like you know has a I think works at the
glacier and then Hannah's one who's like
yeah she was just living in the Attic
for a little while it was a secret I
marry one that has married yes I'm Simon
that has that she's the one with the
primary identity of he was the one with
the secret identity and all through
until the final series of videos you are
she is performing as Hannah whether or
not you believe that that's Eve or
Hannah it's always being performed as
Hannah up to that stage is only into the
final one where she takes the
lie-detector test and that's another
thing about forever but it's only only
then is the idea of Eve actually even
really coming out the police in my
interpretation the police have decided
that because of her tattoo because of
the issue with how she drinks her coffee
that they've come to a conclusion that
there are two people I believe that the
police haven't concluded that they are
twins because obviously at one point
they even asked if they're twins because
Hannah is like things that's just insane
that that would have even been asked and
merely and that's the final video where
you really are seeing Hannah as Hannah
and then she just threatens to leave and
like open the door let me out that's the
final video where we see Hannah and then
the rest is Eve on that on July 3rd the
white blouse yeah the white blouse but
there is an in narrative explanation
just going back to the point of why this
suit like where this their story sounded
so similar
camera one episode there was an inherit
of explanation for that and that was
always there diary right right so in
order to keep track of the various sort
of like lies that they were putting
together like they would come back home
every night with a diary and list out
everything that I usually happens so
when the next person would go out there
would know exactly what to say and what
happened to them so you know just
because the story sounded very similar I
don't think that necessarily means that
there's that's one person reciting the
same thing of course two personalities
it could just be part of their overall
plan yeah how they live their lives
actually but I mean I think there are
differences elsewhere we're like I think
at one point they talked about Eve
meeting up with Simon during that night
when Hannah books it to Glasgow and so I
think just because that those those two
videos are so similar and that they are
essentially two different people saying
that they did the exact same thing means
like to me that indicates that there is
enough confusion in her brain for it to
be for like the the distinction between
two different people to not be real I
have a question for Randall as somebody
who's clearly in the to person can do
you believe that Alford this one of the
things that threw me in that direction
was that a lot of the story if you take
it at face value if you take the secret
girl that lived across the street and
she was still a secret from Simon that
just happens to be and you know if you
believe that it's two people you believe
that Simon runs into this woman wearing
a blond wig who sings in a bar and
doesn't and is taken by the fact that
she's so similar to his wife but is
clearly can't tell that it's the same
woman in a wig do you think that these
things are I mean we've talked about
this before you and I but do you think
that these things are plausible I mean
in the end I actually think that her
being two people in one body is actually
more plausible than what we have to
accept so if there are actually two
separate imple and how did how do you
reconcile that okay so we do have a
discussion about this earlier and it
this is the main thing that is making me
swing more towards the one-person camp
because if you take everything that you
know everything the story lays out for
you at face value
it becomes a fairy tale right it becomes
a fairy tale in the way that you know
like they're always talking about
Rapunzel another fair is right so it's
the whole I'm sort of story of you know
being taking away from your birth mother
and your twin you know at birth and
having to live across the road and see
and see your sister and you know then
having to sort of live in the Attic or
like you know 15 years of your life it
becomes like I'm if it lends a magical
sort of like aura to the entire
narrative which is in in all other ways
a fairly sort of like standard like
crime story so yeah it like I agree with
you it does make more sense if you can
even say that it does make more sense
it's easier to believe that it's one
person who has different facets of the
same personality than it is you know
like two people having this sort of like
amazing sort of like life that they led
apartment together
I don't know if that makes it any more
realistic than it is one person like
it's the easiest solution for sure but I
don't know if it's you know if it's
something that definitely points towards
that there's one person behind this so
you're not swayed you're you get it but
I gained you yes I and I mean to be fair
to support what you're saying about it
being two different people there are
instances like one of the reasons why I
think it's one person's because most the
instances of them talking about two
different people could be you know
plausibly explained by them being one
person with a split personality yeah but
there are certain things like them
walking on the beach and I think it was
Hannah holding you've said more yes it
would yeah well it would be Eve I think
hmm no I mean at that point she's still
playing Hannah so she's still described
bright I think it was handle only you
said but I think I'm a little confused
about which one was yeah which one of
them was holding the others head under
the water out of anger and then there
was also there was also this really
vehement passion towards Hannah the
other twin from Eve when they're talking
about being like things being fair and
then having equal things and sort of
unsure and yeah yeah and that's
something that goes to your exactly have
not talked about
Bru's yeah and you know beyond disease
if that bruise happened that way
in theory this lends support to
Randolph's idea because my idea Kevin
Durant off site of thing which is okay
if you know that lends credence to the
fact that you know Hanna would have had
the bruise Eve would not have the bruise
and so when she's not bruised she's
she's Eve and she's a different person
at that point or man you can cover
anything and fake tattoos this is the
argument for like why the tattoo doesn't
matter but we never get to see what the
police know that's the thing where this
is all unreliable protagonists right
this is unreliable narrator yep so we
can only take we could only take what we
see we never know what the police know
we only know what Hanna / Eve and their
palindrome name tells us and as far as
I'm aware there is no solution out there
right now I think of research the
internet you've actually heard right
that some theories point to it's it's
Eve the whole time and she's also killed
Hanna that's yes I wanted her and the
parents inclusion but what happened to
the parents my theory is that Eve has
has killed the parents my theory
actually whether or not Hannah and Eve
are separate people that Eve is actually
the murderess in this entire as the
secret person or you think I don't know
or I mean Eve was the murderer I think
actually actually the Eve's story about
she walked in and Hannah was there with
the knife and all that stuff I think
that's Apple I I think that's actually a
lie and then Eve herself as the murderer
regardless of whether you think that
it's one person or two I think that the
Eve persona is the one that committed
the murder
I just think it's so fascinating but not
only does that unreliable narrator as
you said Kevin raised all these
questions about what Hannah or Eve did
and who they are but then yeah also like
all these questions about it's the
parents and Simon did Simon know like
when Simon sees her in the bar and is
like wow quite a resemblance like is he
in on the joke does he know that his
wife has this disorder like you can
there's so many questions that's that
spin out of it and it's so artfully
arranged to not just like let you have
your own theory but allow you to explore
it by searching the keywords like it's a
very kind of conspiracy theory friendly
game mechanic right and it just dove
tails so beautifully and I've yeah I'm
sorry and there's the section when they
talk about you know Eve living in the
Attic but even that is qualified by a
story about her being considered
you know Hanna's imaginary friend by
Hannah's parents and so there's just
always with all of these stories there
are multiple excuses and different
explanations and reasons why they could
go one way or another yeah it's crazy
and I mean maybe this gives you an idea
if you've played her story than you then
you already know that it's a very worthy
contender for game of the month and
ultimately our choice in a in a month
with quite a few good games for for that
but tell us in the comments what you
think what is your theory about her
story I guess again this is all gonna be
very spoilery so if you can in the
comments section try to use the spoiler
tag when you're gonna spoil something
but otherwise let us know what you think
let us know what you thought about the
other games this month and keep tuning
in we'll try to have more information
about her story and lots of other games
on gamespot rock on them